it's incredibly easy for me in five
seconds right now to say why my life
wasn't great I can't believe how
challenging that is for me to do on a
day-to-day basis and I'm grateful for
that on the flip side I have unlimited
people I know that are living
spectacular lives in the context of 8
billion people on Earth and they spend
100 of their time thinking that their
life sucks so why I actually invited you
is because I have
some amazing life coaches in Denmark
that have a very important message for
with mental health and I have noticed
that mental health is one of your
favorite things to talk about so can you
tell me and thank you for joining but
can you tell me about what why it's so
important for you to share so much about
mental health and all your content for
the audience my whole life I've always
thought about perspective you know how
you see the world optimism
a lot of emotional intelligence long
before mental health was something that
people talked about in popular culture
I spoke about it privately with my
friends and relatives and employees and
acquaintances
I didn't call it mental health I called
it mindset I called it
the way you see the world I called it
feelings but you know it's important for
me to talk about because I really
believe that life is how you see it
there's seven billion versions of life
and I mean not seven billion different
people I'm talking about for you the
human being
there are so many different ways you can
decide it's incredibly easy for me
in five seconds right now to say why my
life wasn't great
I never do that but I can speak to many
things I can speak to many adversities I
can speak to many shortcomings I can
speak to many moments that aren't fun or
happy I can't believe how challenging
that is for me to do on a day-to-day
basis and I'm grateful for that on the
flip side I have unlimited people I know
that are living spectacular lives in the
context of eight billion people on earth
and they spend 100 of their time
thinking that their life sucks
yeah I think that's unfortunate I want
to be a superhero against that cause
and also I believe that many people in
the world politicians governments
businesses parents
institutions
and unhappy people weaponize
negativity and fear
to trigger people to fall even deeper
into their predisposed concept of
pessimism cynicism woe is me half glass
empty and I would like to fight against
that because I find that people that are
happy optimistic
uh grateful like myself tend to not
communicate enough about it they
actually sit within their own little
ecosystem and so that's why I talk about
negativity being louder than positivity
and I take on that responsibility very
much I think the world right now
um social media is exposing the truth
which is that negativity is louder and
better at recruiting
yeah and uh and I find myself as an
individual who I think is very good at
recruiting
uh but just happens to believe in
optimism and positivity and
happiness and content you know I'm the
most ambitious and most content person I
know
and I'm fascinated by that and how did
you become that
parenting DNA circumstance nature
nurture
um uh having a propensity of being
self-aware and then doubling down on it
once I understood it was happening and
knowing that it was good
um so these are the things I think about
and if if you should share a message to
life coaches in in the year we are
living in right now that actually people
are more depressed than ever so life
coaches is really in need
what would that be
my number one message for life coaches
is
to spend more time on trying to solve
people's problems and spend less time
trying to make money solving people's
problems
yeah yeah my biggest observation is I
have billions of and in reality it's
only thousands I have thousands of life
coaches that are super fans reach out to
me I've met along my journey the last 15
years
and I find that there's a high
propensity of entrepreneurial life
coaches to focus on their business
retention you know one of the things I
spent a lot of one of my greatest goals
in life as a Content producer is to
produce enough content that the person
gets to such a good place that they deem
my content less valuable
and they stop paying as much attention
and they come in for tune-ups not day to
day
I find that a lot of life coaches so
worry about prop and I'm empathetic to
this they so worry about their financial
situation their family their selfish
things that they actually do a poor job
of trying to solve everything
um
because they want the person to continue
to pay them if you're a [ __ ] light
coach then be a [ __ ] life coach have
somebody's life get way better that they
don't need you anymore and let that
build your business not let me hold on
to that person a little longer let them
pay a little more a little longer I I
think that a lot of life coaches fall
into a very dangerous trap of of solving
their life not their client's life and I
think that's why a lot of them stay
small
I think the way to get big is solve
people's problems so that they go on and
live life and they say they meet up with
their cousin and they're like whoa why
are you so happy well I've been working
with this life coach I don't work with
them anymore because I'm good all of a
sudden That Word of Mouth leads to
another customer
and so I would say focus on acquisition
through solving people's problems
AKA solve someone's problems let their
Word of Mouth create new customers
versus retention
and not fully solving someone's problem
I've got this customer
I see that she's struggling with this
but I'm going to keep that for a year
from now so she keeps paying me every
month I
I struggle with seeing that in a lot of
people and I'm very non-cynical
so for me to have this take
on a lot of the people that I see means
means that it is a
it's a scaled issue that needs to be
talked about more
yeah
and so actually when you hear that
Fabiola when you hear that
because that's a very interesting answer
to your question
yeah I love
when that when you hear that from me how
did that land for you what went through
your mind let's play role reversal here
what did you first what did you first
what are you thinking right now after
hearing that
I'm
normally I'm working with the premium
clients and so like a big issue for my
clients so what I I see is help them
with the problem and do they actually
solve the problems and
not thinking about protective retention
in forever and ever but Focus about
solve the problems and then make them
back to life do you agree with me that
there is a propensity amongst the light
the you know life coaches to Pro
expectingly because it's a human being
that they do a little bit at times fall
into categories where they may be more
selfish than selfless
what what I see is a lot of coaches is
buying like hours and just forever and
ever buying like their clients are
buying hours like forever and ever and
ever and not focus about the big problem
they actually have solve it and
and move on go on and like yeah I see it
too I see that it's a place for people
to it's like therapy and a lot of things
it's a place to leave a deposit get
slightly better
yeah but not cut out the root of the
issue
yeah finding the issue solid and then
it's like medicine it's like medicine
yeah the medical industry right like
here's medicine to prolong your life to
mitigate the bad
but meanwhile let's get to the root of
it is your mental happiness in a place
where you're motivated to eat healthy
and work out
that triangle you're meant yes is your
spirit happy enough that you can put in
the work food and exercise wise and get
that whole circle working instead of
here's some medicine so you can keep
eating like [ __ ] the reason you're
eating like [ __ ] is you're unhappy in
your marriage your job your your anxious
you're insecure you're hiding something
and you haven't cut out that poison we
need more people in the world that want
to cut out to the root of the issue not
not what's happening or sustaining the
damage
of the issue
yeah so finding the roots solid
and help you and move on the biggest
like if I was to become a life coach
which is not in my destiny but if I was
I would try to have clients as short as
possible
solve to the truth
and I would build the biggest practice
in the world because more people would
solve versus maintenance
totally
it's like it's like when you get a root
canal it's when you get a toothache
nobody like in tooth in dental care when
you get a toothache you don't go you get
novocaine and then they fix it they fix
it you don't want to go and get
novocaine every 48 hours
but unfortunately with mental health
and with physical health like other
things
we kind of do that we don't solve and uh
you know my mission is garyvee in the
world with my content
old people a lot of times my friends are
like it's you know some people are like
it's very macro I'm like the macro [ __ ]
is the thing like it is about insecurity
and confidence it is it is about
taking poison out of your body and
having a conversation of the thing
that's bothering you the most with
somebody that you love the most that is
the game
yeah
and so a lot of coaches wants to help
the clients but maybe afraid that oh my
God I'm not that type of garyvee that
can just show me to everyone so how do
they what what what what can they think
about all the fear of
showing themselves putting themselves
out there so they actually can help more
people what what would you recommend
well I would recommend that these life
coaches should take their own advice
if you're a good life coach you're
inevitably getting to a place of fear
versus confidence versus insecurity
versus loving oneself versus outside
people's opinions of themselves
so to me
90 of these life coach conversations are
often based on seven relationships
and these life coaches are trying to
explain to these individuals that you
know it's not as scary to confront your
wife or husband or mom or dad or boss or
child and they're trying to build up
their confidence to address the issue
for me strangers on social media are
even less scary than your family you
don't even know them
and so my advice to these life coaches
is eat your own dog food take your own
medicine what you're telling humans is
what you should be doing with content if
somebody says you're stupid or that's
wrong or or you don't get views that
should not be battering your self-esteem
that should be enhancing
you're at best it should be enhancing
your motivation to succeed and at at
least at any level it should be noise
and that's something actually affecting
your journey
um
what's another point in your life now
you have like millions of followers
what's another point in your life where
you actually feel this scary thing of
pudding like oh my God now I reach a new
million and a new million the only time
I've ever been scared of any human
interaction was in my teenage years
asking girls out was scary to me I
wasn't I wasn't confident enough in that
in my young age other than that there's
never been a point in my life where I've
had any thoughts about anything about
anything with human beings
I just don't value that you know when I
was 15 16 17 18 19 even then it started
to fade away I did value what a pretty
girl's opinion of me was I didn't want
that no
other than that other than that 15 to
2019 year old range
there's never been a time in my life
where I valued someone's no in any shape
or form
what are you saying to yourself when
you're not value people's knows what
what is it you say to yourself so you
don't it's a mess it's a mix of I know
who I am they don't and I'm empathetic
that they don't know me how could they
know me we haven't spent enough time
together they don't know how great I am
okay so it's kind of like it's not like
an e like I think a lot of people come
from a place of insecure and they're
like [ __ ] that person like [ __ ] that
girl that boss that guy the audience the
world you know many people say to me at
conferences Gary I'm the [ __ ] best
hip-hop guy the world just [ __ ]
[ __ ] doesn't get it I'm like oh they
get it you don't get it you're
delusional like the world is always
right you're always wrong how it plays
out is how it plays out
you know to me the reason it worked was
I never got mad at anybody for not
seeing me
whether that was a teenage girl when I
was in my teenagers or now I mean
there's a lot of people who still don't
fully understand me in any shape or form
I'm not mad at them
no I'm indifferent
did your mom or your did your family say
something so you actually had that
strong mindset of course my mom you know
my mom instilled incredible levels of
confidence in me because she she cheered
me on and made it to do every time I was
a nice person and my validation system
is
how I treat others
you know my confidence doesn't come from
how much money I make or what I look
like or you know the trophies or the
accolades or things of nature my
validation system is how people feel
about me that interact with me my I'm
not worried about I'm now and I've gotta
run I apologize I haven't leave for a
meeting I now care more about what you
think of me than yesterday
right now right this second because
we've now started the process of
spending some time together I care a lot
more what Dustin thinks of me who's
sitting here filming me right now
because we've had years now of context I
care more of what Alex raffington thinks
of me than Dustin because more years and
she's in my inbox and so she really
knows me I care more what my sister
thinks than Alex rappington because
she's my sister like and so like I think
people struggle with that yeah so I
gotta run cheers okay thank you for
having me on the show thank you so much
Gary have a nice day you too
[Music]